good morning John have to be quiet
because there's a baby sleeping in the
next row so I'm gonna try to be too
excited generally oh that is sometimes
kind of hard for me once I turn on the
camera I tend to spaz out so funny thing
happened your basement flood remember
that from last video that your basement
flooded turns out that the state of
Georgia also um flooded whole state
it's comparable you know your basement
an entire state I'm there in Georgia
right now a state which has forward
three years had a catastrophic drought
not the kind of drought where crop
prices go up but the kind of drought
where you can't shower anymore and now
they're having gigantic floods this is
something that I kind of somehow missed
like I'm here now and it's obviously
news here but I think there's been
something going on in the national scene
that that
overcast the flood thing something no
more important than like nine people
getting killed and six flags being you
know entirely in a watering entire
interstates being flooded and people
like swimming out of their cars to
safety I mean it must been a big news
story if it was bigger than all of that
something I can't remember to us anyway
the rain is coming down here in Georgia
once again although it is not as
significant as the last flood but I'm
here and I'm taking this footage and
it's crazy there it's huge amounts of
water it's gray geing and it's scary
I really don't want to get any closer
than I am to it and it's just weird that
this is happening after three years of
intense drought and not just that but
this summer which is usually a very
rainy time in the southeast the entire
summer two months without precipitation
in Georgia it's very strange and now as
soon as it falls it's just and the
question I've asked myself is is this
normal is this how it works or is there
something else going on here
I have to be friends with people who
know about Georgia rivers I'm currently
in a house owned by a guy who has
surveyed almost all of Georgia's rivers
of which there are thousands and a woman
who works for the Georgia River Network
I'm not profit organization that works
entirely to be the voice of rivers so I
asked him what is going on here and the
answer surprised me first cuz they had
an answer at all but second because it
is as always it seems to be more
complicated than I gave it credit for so
basically there are two things going on
there's climate change which as the name
implies creates a lot of change in the
climate and so you want to weird things
happening that you don't expect like you
expect hurricane season to happen I
the deserts rain doesn't fall but
because of climate change stuff is
starting to really haywire 200 with
places like the southeast that usually
get a lot of rain the summer not getting
any rain and that's not just a big deal
for people who want to take showers and
eat food it's also a big deal for trees
that need lots of water in the summer so
that they don't die and then we you
don't have lots of water and they do die
the entire ecosystem of the entire
southeast changes climate change means a
lot more change than just the climate
climate change is like global everything
changes get ready the second thing that
is happening is this Georgia is really
paved when you lay down something like a
house or a road or a driveway or
anything that is impermeable to rain you
wind up with way more flooding and way
more drought now first this confused me
but it really makes a lot of sense
basically instead of that water hitting
the ground and soaking slowly into the
groundwater it shoots straight into the
rivers and goes straight down to the
ocean so when you get these floods the
amount of water in rivers skyrockets
immediately and then as soon as the rain
stops falling it drops just as fast
whereas before when the rain was falling
on soil the water would hit the soil and
then slowly seeped through the whole
system now the water goes straight into
the rivers and never hits the
groundwater at all it just shoots
straight into the ocean and that's a
huge reason why urban areas are having a
harder and harder time having enough
water to quench the thirst of their
populations it's no good but I'm glad I
know that now and hopefully John you're
glad you know that - next time the water
invades your basement just think of all
the horrible things that you've done for
water in your life not the least of
which is constantly converting it to
urine jerk John you'll see me tomorrow